money is I've called it fiction because
it's something that we've collectively
agreed is a thing money is whatever we
say it is anything can be money
throughout history all kinds of
different things when money shells have
been money like sticks with like notches
carved in them have been money anything
could be money it's just something kind
of stands between transactions that
we're making because it makes things
easier we use the pound in this country
the dollar is like the Global Currency
well why are they moving because
everyone agrees and it's great if
everyone agrees on something because it
means that you can like go out and buy
pretty much anything you want you've got
an established unit to use
[Music]